>> IAIS ISRE GATO TEE S
YO
>>ES Y.
H IEAV TO SRTTA OFFY B
SANGOT NOO CL.
A AUREONIC FTIRRI WTERE WHE
YOUAD INVURGIN OPA SCEH WIT
ICNONF
ONTI?
AYOU TREHE QENUE OFONIC FTI
LI
YKEOUAV HE A GCANIGTI
KINDMDO AT' IS NOTUG ENO
H
HYOUOEAV TE COMVE ORO T THE
ICNONFONTITE WRIRS WLDOR AND
JU
OL DSTEMSHIS US AEL WL.
SATWH ING GOIN O.UI QCK
>>SAY THEAN M WHOSRI WTE
NO ATIICON A FAMSOU
MUNDANCI AAS H P A.CAODST
GH[LAUR]TE
D I>>OAN WTO TTA SRTFF OY B
ASNGND AHE T TNOVE CARUT O A
NI
SECH I ARE GAT
UNMETARSTE.NT
TDAN I IS ALI BPN I THEON LG
NCTFIIONGRI WTIRAR CEEND A
THLYLU FIDOI GNG
NDCKBA-A?OR-FTH
>> SOHE TNT ITIENONDEH BIN
ISTH ISH WIT AERHELZIM'S
DECA.DET FOR WLDR OORVE AR
SATTH IUP SERTAMP IORNTOR WK
TOERE PYNASOLLND AO T YOU TO
DISENDEAS AE BES LSAI AFRD OF
IT
ELIARERGN DIANDISOS A
URRESOORSCE FAR CEND A
ARRESECH BUT THEVE CONATIO
ALENEVTUFT SLYHIEDO T MOREMY
ANTTOR FGEGINN IER GEN.AL
FO
VESLK O TRHEGE A O 4F0
LYNIFITE0 5 AREEDRE FAK OUT
TRDAN S OSEESD AUTNDEDOR WRI
SHDAN AFEDAM OVE ERY DAY
SMEMONTORF O NORLMA FGTTGEIN
HETBU T'T DYONNO KWT' IS
NO.AL
CIESPEFTLYAL AER AER C AINTAGE
IMYER T IEAL WKNT IO AOO R
MEV
CAND RNOANTREMEMBEHY W I
WA IEDNHE TRE IAN CTNO
REHEERMB TAM NE OF THEIE MOV
ORHE TCT AOREN WTO THE T
GRTOYER S ARENDTOR FGO THE
PMILK APLEOE WRERIOREDT IS I
IGA S ONF INGENMPDITIEM DEN
AES
LYCIPEAL AIT WHED LOVNE O
WIIMLZ AHE'SER.
IETHONENNTTIEEC BAME WAV HE
TOUENGHES SOTRBOS A IUTNS THI
WORL IF I CANAK TEHI TS OFF
OF PSPLEOE'TE PLA D YS,OU'TON
HA SO TESTRSUT ABO TSEHE
TH I IGSTS A NMAORLUT OMECO
HOUMUR O H BANINRASRE A
DE
EDGN.
I TAN WTOEL HP TMHEER UND
AD
ITHIS HSOW YROUIN BRAOR WKS
ALNORMGE FLYOR ATSNDHI TS ISTO
YHOWANOU CCTRO PTE ITND A
EPRIMOV THA TT ISHISHA WT YOU
LYREAL TAV HEO AOR WRYUTBO.
BU WOS MTTHABOVE ERYDY
SRGFOET DVE ERY 2R O 65S I
TO
LLTAYOR NLMA.
NEOM SEOLO FOLNUPW- OY M
ESTIU, YOAV HETT WRIEN
VEFI BKSOOIT WH A LOT OF
ILDETAHA WTHE TUSAR VIO
OGURNEOLALICEA DISSSE AREO S
IDYWH DOU YAV HEO TWI SHTC
EROV?
WHAT WASSAEC NESUT ARYBO
NGCOMIO TCTON NFINIO SCEINOU Y
UCEAR S AHNRT A ATIS
EDDD
K.QUIC
>>L WTIL BO GKAC T TOT.HA
I
ON W'TVE ERO GAC BK TO
NO
ONICNFTI.
INJO EOYONIC FTIE MOR
E'THERE MSOROO RM TO PYLAY M
BNEXTSKOO I AEL NOVIT W AH
WO
ITNMA WOL BHIP AARNDRI WTE
ABIC ATDDFTONTI AER TT.HA
TBU IVEES RERHE THT RIG TO DIP
TOINCTON NFINIOAU BECSES THI
EDSERVHE TON N-TI FACON
AFOATRM ASAT GREEH VLEIC I
NTWAEDHI TS TEE F LLEIK A
FRCCLYND AESIESBL
COONSAERTIIT WH A FENRIDHO W
ENHAPP B TSOE AEU NNTSCROIETIS.
E HIAVN BEEOI DNGHI TS IN
PE
NEONRS OT A A TE.IM
OMLEOP C TEOE MON CGSSFEIN
AL TSTOET G DEDGNIAOSSE THE
HAN BEEAP HNIPENGO T ME.
ANI CTNOEMEMRBEAM N IESF I
DOTE WTRIT IOW DN AND I
FO
ETRG.
CYOU SANEEHE TEA FRIS RGIN I
VEHAO T LET TMHE KNOUT BHE TY
DOE HTAVLZ A'SIMHEER I
EXHANAI W ITSOI GNGN O AND I
EENCA S THEEL RFIE.
ASIT W VYERLE CARHE TRE IS A
NE TUT OREHEO TND UDSTERAN
EVIVAYYD L TESHERY EVEAY D
MOFSNT OTTOR FGENDGIN A W
THATPE HAPHANS WTO TE B
CO WNEERDNDHIT AHA WTOT NO T
ABENDO ALSEW FAL WKNT IO A
ROANND A C'TBEEM REM IRAN C
HE FOU YURIGET I OUTND A
PN'DOT
ICAN.
EAIT RASYLL W A MSIISONO T
EHELPRYON WHO WASOR WED
ABT MOREMYOR W ARYUTBO THE
TRIGHSHI TNG LND AETO G OFHE T
ST.
HI>> TON RSES WESATHITE ON
SE
DRAVELNTFEIFRES.EV LEL
AS A PSOERNE COM I D'TON TNKHI
THNYSE' ANER PSOR OVE0 4ND A
IM A 54.
S TTHHITYNX AIE FOR A BCHUN
OF YRSEA.
JNOTTUS THENE OIC PANTOM MEN
T H NEVERGND EINER SSIEF O
DECE CONRN MENOMTS ISHA W
T
ORIM FGTTGEINS I ITLOR NMA?
INGETTER OGLD IR O IST ME
BEGOIAR PAN ODROM S IHIETNG
SH
ELDOU BEDOR WRI AUTBO?
EVUG THOH NOW IM AEDRA TIN
NDTO UDSTERANHE T DNCFEIFREE I
EILSTLNCERXPIEEHA TLI FEENG
LI
YRATELLOOU Y GO INTLL A THE
BO
OKAL TKS AUTBOIMLZ AHE'SER
DANTH OEREA DISNDSSE AT WHA DO
PET WLEANO TAL TKUT ABO?
EAISTH FHER T HYEAVY THE WTAN
TO
E BUREA RSSEDND AOL TDE LIK
REUYO AHE TDU CONIT TO THE
CCADILTYMUOMNIN I A WAY SOE
RYSTJU TOGIN T PUTSE THO
ERANSWN DSOW F INDOUHI T BSKOO
SO
ER PYNASOLLUREA RSSOGIN T
ANOT AER L OFHE TUE QIOSTNS
ATO IWENSR MNYD MIN FOR MY
ARSECHUT B IN' HADUTT POW DNE
SO
YHA TNKOU FOR TTHAIR FST OF
ALL.
T T>>HAS IL WEL AATICRTUL
H MUAYEAV ASE SEN I CNOANTEDYO
FIY MHO PNE I C'TANBEEM REMR
IERWHEUT PY MNE PHO IANNO
T
MBREME G MERYSSLAES.GA AIN
MTHEEPCOISNCSONTI IHIOM SET
NS
OOI GNGNIT WHY MOR MEMYS I
FAT'GIN ITI GSETER ONGLD
WH
IATSNIAP HPE?NG
OUTBU YOR MREMASY WBLRO PBAY
TNO IDOLNVVEN IHE TSE
INANCE YSOUNO CANTT AERE CAT
A
YEM MORF I YOU D'TONAY P
NNTTEIOHEO T TNF IONMAORTIT
IN
IRHE T FST.LA PCE
NK TSOHIFGIN O THEER VYEX NT
TH N YGOUDEE TOO DOT N
SEGLASN DSOW LHE TNERATT I
TISN'YEM MOR IT ISACIS DTRONTI
NDTO UDSTERANHA TTHE WN I
TCAN' MIN FDHOY P PNEYBAROBL
IUSCAETID DN'AY PTT ATIENONBE
TO PUTT IHE RAT TRNHA
GMPJUINYO T MEM MYOR IS
GILFAIN SO TOAY L IT DNOW ON
RPAPEAN CEA RYLL HPEL.
'S L>>ETK TAL AUTHE T
BI
IESGGTNADE I THEOO BK
YTEVERSNGHI ICI NARCISSSTI I'M
SO
YLA GDOUPENT ACH BUN OF
TI
ME ON TSHIEEF BOR WEET G
TINTOHEON CIORSVEATNF O T
NDSIN AS OUTF O HOWYEM MOR
IRKWOSFE DNIFINNTRE KDSF O
, MOMERYIGETH BDE IAOR F ME IS
TH
A WATE NREOTIG DES TDNEO
MBMEER ERYVELET DAI INAC FTRE
IFE WE WERE WOU WLD NOT HEAV
THSOW PERF OLINT IEL ANCGEEND
TOABRDGNKHIIN WHA TTEO D
HA
.VE
WE AREES DNEIGDO TTOR FGEHE T
AJSTVA M OITORY TFHE DAIETLS
WE
AOM CE
OSCRS.
ETHEREORE A P WEPLHO ARE
ERCUENMB R BEDYRIEMEMBE TNGOO
MUAI DETL.
SO AKALUTBON I A BIGAY WOW H
OUSRA BIN AREES D NNEIGD TO
RE
MMBMEERTOSHI TS.NG
TH CE WANET GO T WTHA WREE A
GNDESI R TEDOREMEMBEND AHA WT
ISKI WOR ANGNDHA WTS IOT N.
>> HST'PFELUL TOAK TEIM TE
TO TNKHIUT ABO WTHAE WLL REA
Y
EMDO R ABEEMR WNDTHA WE
DO
T.N'
'T DIONBEEM REMR ASUC MHM FRO
RNTE OIV FEEA YRS AGOND AHA TT
I AGEORTOT LF O DAIETLSRO FM
TH
AS PT.
ILD WOURG AUEOU Y D'TON
REER YR MTOSEC RTEN
STPA.
YTODA ISDA MONY.
ON AEE WKGODA MONAN YOU
MTELL TEHEEX TTES M YGESASOU
SE
ANTND RD?EIECVE
UT AATBOOU YROR MNGNI
.OWSHER
WHOUID D Y FAV HEORCH LUN?
WHATEAS I MLNGNIFUND A RBEEMR
EM
L.IOOTNA
SUOESERI G ISNHE TREEC BSEAU
TH
TSLI ECITI EMO BONUTHA WT
NI MISEA AFUNGLATND MRSTEE W
REEERMB WTOR FGEHA WT
IS
O OSTFIVUR LESRE APE SNT
TINDOG TNGHIS ATHARENEOU RTI
HANDLITABUA DAYOD TAYSRA BIN
RN'DOTREMEMBEAM SELD O.
WE SNTUC MH OF OURS DAY
HEGIN TE SAM TNGHI WE HEAVO
CO S WEEEITN OOO ZM CLS.
YSOOUL FEEUZ FZYVE ORHE T
PA AEA YRND AIT LETLOG FGY
ECABEUSIDE W DETTN' G OUT AND
ADOSY MANSHI TNG ITTAS WN'
ERDIFFTTEN IAS WHE T SEAM DAY
YTODAND OUR BINRAGE FORT A
RO
INUTE.
IFANOU WTO T REMBEORR ME
OF HTHAPEAPNS INOU YRIF LE
AVUYO H TEO GETUT O OF YROU
AINUTE PNDUTEW NHI TSNGN IRO
IT
HA TTREONMO ETI AALND
GSTHINHA TT ARERAT MTEO T YOU
TH
HA'SAT WT WEEM REMRBE.
TLL ASEHOAT VAC DNIOSAYOU Y
EMNCA RBEEMR VYERCI SPECFI THE
EXCONT T OTF DTHAAYAS W LIK
E
THNO ONER I LOU YRE.IF
W>>EAL TKBO AUT THENG THI
S
WTHAT NEREW ANDNGEA MNILFU
ANINXC EIT YGOUAV HE AHA CENC
EVTO RHAITIS TTYEM MOR AND
TIPERETIPS HONELO TBEEM REM
NF RDEI TCEORSEN SHETR OHGTFRAN
TH
EUEOS NLRACTON CNENSIOID D
THSOMEOOGIN CIT ELXCGIN IIL WL
YLLTE MEN FRINDDS A FILAMY
AIAGNND A AINGAND AT THA
REGSCNIIN TEL HPSNF ROEICEOR
THEYEM MOR.
>>NTNGOI I NOIEROEUSCOUENC Y
VEHA AHD P INSCEU NRONCIEE.
YCASILLREOU Y A WDEROM WAN.BA
VEYOU'TOT G I. ALL
MYNSTUEIOND AERY
SPLYICIFAL MTOSIEEM MORES W
REERMBNGEA MNILFUR O
EMNAIOLS IHE TEA R WNSOE
ERMEREMB TSEHO BAUECSE OF TTHA
EM
LIOOTNA MENOMTE LIK THE
CH
ERLEALNG BWILONGP? U
ITEAS SDREN IUR OOR MEMRY O
ISHE T RSOEANT THA IS THE
RYMEMON IHE TVE ENTE WEE KP
GOR OGVE OND ARVEN IUR O
SHEADNND A ION CIORSVEAT?NS
HO
S DWOEHA TTOR W IKN THE
BIFYOG O OURRA BUISIN Q.CK
T>> ISH BOT.
OWTGH NR OAL TKBO AUTHE T
FNDKI OYEM MOROR F SNGETOMHI
TH
PE HATAPD.NE
DATTH'SNTFEIFREGIIO BLOLLCAY
FRHE TTU SFFT THA YOUW KNO.
OEESPDIGF LHT0086 1,0IL MES
ECRPE SRDON OHE TTU SFFT THA
YONO KW.
THEYEM MOR HOW TO DONG THI
TKEOAV HE A CAR ORE TYP ORSLI
WR B AEEIKT THA IS
ENFFDIERT.
SOHT RIGOW NER WENGAL TKIOS M
T
HAOF TPE HTAPD.NE
ICISEPODEM MYORS IFF STU TTHA
SHAAP H RNEPEDLLEAYLU INFCEEND
EANDDANNHCE BYTI EMOON.
THSOMEAPGIN HNSPEMO ELYONTIAL
NEL.RA
IHTIG RREMEMBE IT IFT IS I
SC E OYRGITXCINR OFU JOYL OR
TR IICFHE TRES I ANONMO ETI
UIDAN B A-ILTN TTHEE SAMIM TE
TH
L WATILIBON CTREUT TO TTHA
NOTEMIO SEI BNGONGND
ASNGLO-LIONGTI BLLGILOCA
AUSCAE OAR PT TFHERA BINYBE
CA
EDLLHE TMY A PALGDATARF O
ETHCIM LBIYS SMTEND A H AAS
TLO OFTIR DECON CNCTNEIOVE OR
TH
ECAIP HPOUSMP ITS I A
STURCTEHA TT IT RSUIEQRE THE
RMATN O AFNYEW N
SLCINSOUYEL HDOR MEMSIE SO
ECABEUSHEF O T RIRNSATELIOPHI
E HWEAV AY VER THTIGD BON
AMYGNDLADA AHE TCAIP HPOUSMP
THAT CSNEONCT THE DNTFEIFRE
ASSCTND ANTLE EMEST THA
NNTCOAIEM R AEM MREBED OENOMTR
ENPEEXRI.CE
HE T ONEAN HDND AIO MOT
N
NGSTROLU ILYNFCEENSEF I W
ERMEREMBHIOM SETNG OROTF I
EIT'SALTIMOON WE WLILAL TK
OUABTT. I
WATTH'SETTHA GS OURTT ATIENON
LI
P AKEEITOSIVACEE FDBOOK LP
WHAYE W P AONENTTTIO? T
WATAS A BIGMO EONTIHA TTTH
GE YROUTITT AENON YOU CNOANT
RE
SMBMEERNGETOMHIOUF I Y
PN'DOTEN AAYTTONTI TOT I AS A
FIVDREM BTONO TAP CEOD C
TROACSS BDGEHO TANUSDSF O
S.TIME
AYI MMI 1BE0  PSLET TO THE
GEBRIDUDND A S TNLDEYNKHIHA TT
EA AILR GDYO ORHE TRI BE?DG
I
RAN C'TR.EMEMBE
[L
R]GHAUTE
IAN C'TEM R DBEEMRVINGVER
LOCOOUALSS FLAR-NERI BEDG
BE DEUS I P'TONAYTITT AENON
ITOT BUT IFODOM SEBE WYER
DISTAN T ONGNHERI BBOEDG A
UT
UMTO JFFP OOR F AAR C AIDEN
ISEB SOMYODLE CALD AND TREHE
NGMA AZIEW NSEB SOM
Y'ODS
GETTGEDAR MRIN'M I O THE
GEID, IIL WLEM R
BEEMR
INDRIVR OGVEHE TRIDG
HA T
DAY.
IOEMOTLL RNEAPS HYELS UAY P
NTATTENDNIO AOR FM MSOREMIE
SP
HITEN T ISS P ATARF OHE T
IN IIERVWON D'TNO KWHE W
RE
TO GO.
ANSO M TYNGHIS IAN W TTO ASK
HETBU TRO P REMBLHTIG NOW IS
YO
K TUALYOU CNTBEEM REMR
TINTHGSTHAN' DIDTNAP HPEO S
HO
S DWOEHA TT HPEAPN?
ITHATNOS A HERTHEUG
MIANERNDSTNGBO AUTEM MYOR
LEPEOP VAV HE MIDIVSOREMIE
FRON LGGO A ANDT WHA TYHE
MEMBER HASN BEEOU WNDO I
TOETH ST TRYHA DN'IDT AYUACTLL
HA
ENPP.
>> I MTAY NOTAV HENEAP HPE ODR
ATLL A TTHAOU YID D NOT
EXCERIPEEN YHA TTOROU BWRO
FR OERTHE.EO PPL
RIMEMO T FESOR SHEFFTUT THA
ENHAPPEDGA AINTU SFFOU YW KNO
HOROWO T DOR OO DAT LERER VY
ABLNVUERLEO TTI EDI.NG
THTU SFFHA TTNEAP HPET TDHA
RYOUEMEMBERS IRO PBLBAY
WILYCC INAATURE.
THEESE' B ANLLIN KDS OF
TESTUD OSNONIMY.WISES
LEPEOPVINT IEREDEWUS J ATERFT
TH
CE SEPALEHU STTENHA CLLRGE
ER AORFT/1 91ND AHA W YTOU
RE
TMBMEERNHEVINT IERED
AG TNWORS YEA LERATHE T
ESMOMERIRE AAL TOTLY DNTFEIFRE.
TESTHEODEN T B CLEOLGE
TSUDSTEN'SHE TRE ARE GAT SDYTU
OF
GEOL CLENTTU SDESE TSHE ARE
PUNYOG NPLEOEOT ANGGISRA BIN
EYMA BOR MEMMPY IREAIDHE TSE
0EAR 2-OYE -ARNTSLD IEDVIEREW
IMYATDIEL TFT AERCE SHEPA
EUTSHTLENHA CLLERRGE V
WYET
WTHANOUTHA Y AREOI D WNGTHA
DI
S YDOU
.EE
DHOWID YOUEE FLN THE
RVINTE AWEIEDWOINGA TEA YRS
LA A TRHEWENSRSON D'TCH MAT
STALMOT A A.LL
N TDHEWN SHO THEGI ORILNA
ITNDHAWRHEGIN TK LYOO ATT THA
SANDHAAY TTS IGETR SAN
.
CTHAT'TANE BIG RHTHE TYL WIL
KSTICHEO T TAL FSEOR MEMS.IE
IT IS HGBLUMINN I ANY
SSITEWNEMOES TTI W INYS
NGO
OMUCHF THEWHIM TE SHIC I
HTFRIGINENGSI CON HRIDENG
OW
NOFTEELE W RYN O IT TOVI CONCT
LEPEOPF I IHO SD THEID VEO
OF AAR CCC A AENIDTNDHE T ANSK
YO
ER AUFT HRDWAST FOWASER WE
THAR CSOI GNGHE WNHE TY
COTEACDAC EH OERTHOU YD SAI
IL30 M I BESUTF ID SAI HOW
MUOWR O HAS FT ARE TYHE
GO
HEGIN WNHE TYEDRA CSHE H
DWOUL TAY SYHEER WENG GOI
STFAERO S WTHAPE HAP ANSERFT
WEEM RBEEMR SNGETOMHI
NCFLINUE W HESOWATE LER
REEOR IT.
ANWE CY ONLAP CRETUHA WT WE
APAYONENTTTIO TN IHE T
IRT
E.PLAC
IFSSIT WNEET SEDOMRNGHI O
EXENRICEOM S MHIETNGYRA BIN
NISOT AID VEOAAM CERT I
RN'EST EORECDITRYVE SEN I
IUNSODOS E'MXPOED T IL WIL
APLYON CRETU ALI S OCEFT WHA
ENHAPP.ED
TSOOEG BIN WHIT MYEM MYORS I
EDBIAS WRO FMTHANEOM SEO ELSE
SE
.ES
5A4AR -YELD-OAN MIT WGSSNEIN
SOINTHGIG MHTOT NEIC
ENFFDIERME ETLENSNT I2 A 2
-Y
DR-EAOL.OM WAN
EMURYO M WIEORSIFLIL DRFEO T
NBEGIIT WH.
IHEREHES TEI WRD PTARVE ERY
EMETI WAL RECL THE MOREMY WE
HAVE THEBI ATYLIO T ADDR O
SURCTRA ORING IN NEW
IN
IORMFOAT
RTE/1 91I, CH WATED NSEW
RESRT I MAYNC ITEPOORRAHA TT
HATOIN WPE HTAPMMDNE ILYIAEDTE
AF
T OEMNHEHO PNEIT WH SEOOMNE
WH
SATHEAY SSER HOT NESIC
IN WNCUEESTHA IEM RBEEMR I
MA
VE LYEA ITIORNFMAONUT O TO
TMAKEHETO SRYND SOU TTHA OR I
MA
AYDDMANF IOROONTI T CNEONCT
ETH DSOTVEHA WTEPE HRAPNDNE I
TH
EL REETRNGLI O THE
NIREMIINSCGS I RRIEWTE AND
OORSTEDIKRVE LAVE S IGINN
OFCRMIOSORT W IDTOE GSR OVE
THRI ONAGILEM MYORHE T
ALIGORINYEM MORS IE. GON
LOW NEIK THEEL THOEPNEAM GE
ORETH M WEE TDOL THE MOREMY
TH
TH FEUR IERT HAS THE
OPYUNRTITO T MRAIGTERO FM
WH
WAS MY FSTIRYEM MORF O
VEATTH EEA YRSAT LER IL WIL
ARBE FM FROHA WT IGI ORILLNAY
ENPEEXRIFDCE IOU Y HEAV
SIHIGSIN T A ISSOO CL
SEEREXCIEM REMOLRBE H FAYIDMRO
YO
LD CURHIRODHO ON AVE ENT
TH OLL AF YOUSSIT WNEED.
TH BMYROMY TEROMEM REM ARBET
CH
SSTRIMA W IAS TEN YOUE WER
EI I ATNDAY M SAY I HEAV A
RYMEMO HE MAYAV HE A
TEMPCOLELYREIF DFENTEM MYORF O
XAATTH E SEAM DAY.
SO AOUYUACTLLON D'TNO K OWR
CAW KTNOHO W IIG RHTR O
WR L AGNDELIKYOU YOT B HHEAV
TH
OR IISNF ITIMAONOUN YRWN O
.MOMERY
>> SO I HEAVWO TLO FOLUPW-S.
THSRA BINRE A THEOS MT
FA MTIASCHIACNEVE ER
INTEDNT IIL WLAK TE AHI WLE
HARFO TOT TE.HA CNG
WWHYVOLDOU E DTILUONIGESN A
NBRAIHA TTOU CLDNG CHA TEHE
WA
WYEBEEM REMET SROMNGHAT
HAEDEN?
TH MOU WLDEAKS UBL UNA TEO
KN
IOWF THAEM M IYORS A TE
ME ORYR SENSEUBQUYTLTE EDID?
CIANER UND HANSTDOWE WT WAN
ORTO FM A BIGNT INTLIELGE
E CTPIUREEDAN KRO IPMPNGVI ON
TH
TATOAK ME ITOR MEUR ACCEAT.
OTTBU N TO KWNON IOU YRWN O
HE
IF IT' ASE TRU MOREMYR O
THSOMEOUGIN YEDHA CNGLO ANG
ETHAY W ITOU C MLDEAKT IOR W
TONKHI ORTNS IISVE EN
AINOKGDE ETVIHAENC T ITTS I
NO
TT WHA SPSTO THEES D ONIGF
OU
N?BRR AI
FTHESTIRBV OUSIO AWENSR WE
E NFE POTER WCTERE SO
LELLFAIB IHI TS'TSNHE TNL OY
CESTINAN THE WRE BHEINSRE A
ESTNO DNEIGDOR F RRIEMEMBE
NGEV
YTHI.
SEER I A STRGEOXAR PAD OF
RYMEMONHE TNE OAN H IDF I
DCIDEDETE W IAND TO MEOREMIZ
10IG000 DSIT OF PIY M BINRA
IS
LEAP CAB OF TTHAENY AON CAN
AN JAAPNGEES E AEEINRTHE T AGE
6OF 1 IIZEM MOREDVE OR,0 10000
UGIDITSH HPIGEC BSEAUE H
NTWAEDO. T
CWEANEA L NRNEWAGAN LGU AESND
PLAYUIR.TA
AN CEM REMRBETH ANYGIN.
ITLIL FGEORTO T TEAKR YOU
VI
MITAN.
S IHE TOS M ATINOUSTND
GPI
EEC OFQU EMEIPNTVE ER
EDAGIMIN ANDT IIL WLAK M
E
ZARRYELPL SIMEIS MKETAS.
ONI DE H'TAV THECT EXA AWENSR
FO
YROUUT B IAN CO ALSMA INEGI
IOOLEVUTN WE MSOREMIEOR F
WHATPE HAPDNE OUR
COIVORABAT D IET JSNOE'TTUS
PEDEND ON YOU I CANY ONL
ERMEREMB IHA WTAI PDEN ATTONTI
TO I'M GNAONIS MS A LGEAR
OIORTNFHA WTAP HNEPEDT JUS
TFRHE BNGINEGNIEEO PPLAL TK
TABOU EESWIYETNTI TSES INYMOF
SERTHE'K B AANBE ROB FRYDIN
E OERYNL P HNSOESSIT WNEED
HWHATDPEAPNE M IAYAV HEY ONL
TSEENUNHE G BUTOT NIS HAC FE
ECABEUS W IASO S FUSOCEDN O
OUATWH CL KLDILE.
SBUT EEOOMNE WELSHO ISOT NN I
INETH LEF O FEIRLD COU SEEIS H
NDCEFA AAY MBEHE TLI ABI TTYO
ABCOLLATOREN OYEM MORPS HEL
TGE ARUL FLEIC P FRETUOR WTHA
HA
AENPPED ANDS AYP BDUROCT WE
CAAYOTNN SWAHA WT  MSY
CERIPEEN VER SSSUEOOMNELS EE
T WORHA WE MEAD UPEC BSEAUE W
VEHA GATRENAMA IGI WONTISHIT
GRYTSTT OR.LEELRS
OUIN BRRAS LEOVTO SRYINNY ATHG
CWEANP WRA OURIN BRARO ADUN.
>> I AOSLMTMP STOED YOU IAM CE
OSCLE.
S IHE TRENY A WAY FORS UO T
SOWKN A WEEM RBEEMRHIOM SETNG
ANPOIMRT W ITFEYEA RLLE CAR TO
FOWKN IE' WREN OHE TSSIT WNE
ST IDSHE TRE A WAYO T HEAV
ATRUEEURCCATYEM MORR O WE
DIVEHA ELODTE A TNGHEAY W?
WDOEUS JT GEIVP UND A
ACELEOWDGVEHA WTE WERE
RE
INMBMEER IGSHE TTO SRYE W
HTTAUGLVUR OSEO T TLEL
ICQUK.
T>> I INKHIST' THEES BTE W
CA
DNO.
ETHER TEE NDS BOE AN
ACMELEOWDGNTHE TRE AREOM SE
OUTHE TRE WHOOU PNDHE T
WMEVENTHIT AES MGESA OUR
ODEPISOR MICEMRESIE AO S
FAIBLE CHE TY CANUTTRONIB
ETO
AAS CEO TERE CAT A PTUICRE
USBECAIO OEBVELYUS WON D'T
OEDNE TPE SLLT IUT ONT E
ELY
EIF WIT WSSNEHIOM SET ONGR
EX
CERIPEENOM SHIETNGTA CER
LN
ETHERNS I A EMELENT OF TTHRU.
IT ISETOM CPLYELFF O.YIL WDL
BUST I I SJEUBCT TO ALLIN KDS
OF
S.RR EOR
OSTJU T SOL HD'SEOOMNE
TE
YIMSTON ASTH TRU IS
DA
SERNGOU.
'SIT AIE PCE OF THEUZ PE.ZL
FO
RLEXA EMPF IOU YP KEE A
NDYAR AOU YTE WRI DNOWT WHA
ENHAPP YSOU AREOR ME LELIKYO T
ERMEREMB YHA WTROOU WTEOW DN
D OERTH ESMELENTAU BEC
SEAN
CTHATEAN B AUE QUER O A
RIGTRGETHOR F OCE PERIE OSF
APATWH HNEPEDT THA. DAY
PS HITEL TOSHNL UEA THEEST
TOFHEEM M IYORF YOU KPEE A
ARDIYT IAN CO ALSE B LSES
ACFTERA I IRI WTE SNGETOMHI
WNDOT IAN CIT LIM WTHA I
ERMEREMB TNL OY WOTHA IRO WTE
DO
H IWNEAVSIMP EHA TDZETHAO S
CHMU IIG MHTIS MS OERTHSHI TNG
ATTHAD H HDPEAPNEUT B NOWT I
HAAC A REHA TTRO FMHE T
MOMERYT I IS SO FE GON
USBECA I NEOWAV HEREES RTOD
DAN REDISEVITY OHI TSPS ATEC
OF HTHAASNEAP HPEHED T OERTH
PI
AVESEC HEE GWA A AYND YOU
CNNCAOTEVIONNCE MY THE
EDCUOCRR.
SSITEWNEES T IMOTINYS
IN
LYEDCRIBDLA FWEYOB NOD
SHR ELDVEONE B C BCTVIEDEDAS
WI EONYE TESTNSNYTIESMO
E.ALON
NEALIO BLLGILOCAYHA T ITS
AN
D INCEUS JTI.
HE>> T LAW EMEORNFCENT
YUNMMITY BND AGE LAROE DS
UN TTARSNDOWTHA N
ADE'V HOL R AEV TIOUTNHE
PA0 2.EA YRS
STSSRO PFE BNAIOLSORUT CCTRE
MEF I ANG WMRO.
NMI' I THE MOREMY FLDIE SO I
KN TBO AUTS.HI
TBU IOU WLDMA IOSNEGI M
SOONRUD JSGE AND AYSORTTNE
KNHI TST? FAC
T T>>HAK BAC ITP USEEC BAU I
CEPOLIERFF OICS ARERA T IEDINN
ETH ICELUNFENF OHE TIR
LA
AUANGGE WHAEB SOMYOD
WODEM RBEEMRE LIK THE
IPLAME IFHO S YWOU A VEOID
AN
DEHA CNG ONEER VBFT ASWOERRD
HO WAS FTEERHE TAR CSOI GNG
AYEON DCTON CTAED AREEDMA SSH
I
IL WLEHA CNGOU YREMORRO FM
WH
YATOUAW SAS B OEDN THE VBER
IF
A IM AOL P OEICICFFER I AM
QUGONTIIN AIT WSSNE
RRINTEGATOGINNEOM SEO DHA WTID
YO
UEE S?
ANMY L CAGGUEAN VYERH MUC
UEINFLHAENC W TTHENER PSOIL WL
SAHE TYAW AND CDASOONLITE
TOEM MYORUT BHE TGU LAN
EAG
USEDOIBES DCRE WTHANEAP HPED
WIENNF ILU F ACEURUTE
REONECLLTIF OHA WTAP HNEPED
SPN WKHEHE TER INTEWVIND ES
WE
AN CIT POLYELAY SDB GOOYE
HEDAN TOLN C AORNTGES TO SEE
WHAS WUT ABOOI GNG ON
EY TNEITSSNYTIESMO.
TEAU[LGHR]
AY MNTGES IN OPE SEDL DIA
K BSOACO T THEK BOOAT, WHS I
IMORENTORMPTA TOOU Y?
DUO ACH BUNF O ITIERNTES
NGH
NGSIN I THE BK.OO
IISTO T RESSEAUREO PE?PL
ALTO TBOK AUTHE TEA RCEURSSAN
OFGERNTINNT IOHE TK BOO AND
TH PAK MESPLEOEHO WO G
THHUGOR NLMAHING
UN TTARSNDSSHI IHE T WAY THE
NSBRAIRE AUI B ALTNDHA WT WE
SAREDPOUPSEO TE B
CIRIPEENNG A TNDTHA IN
ISEITLFSUG HEIC MEDEINUT B
THNGEL HPIEEO PPLSTND UERDAN
ETH DNCFEIFREESIT WH THE
GSRKWOINF OEM MYOR.
DAD AINER CTANT POIEO PEPL
WAO TW KNO SFFTUUT BHE TY
DOT WTANO T LRNEA THE
SC
NCIEE.
THEY TAN WTNDO UDSTERANHE T
SSIBACS HOOWO D YOUATAV NIGE
ATTH?
ER>> VEN IYNTLYONTIALID I D
WNOT TTANHIO TEE F LLEIK AN
ACICEMTB TEXK.OO
I NIDOTAN WTT IO T BE TOO
LO.
OONE TFHEPT CHAHOSER S IRT
WA
EDNT EHACPT CHAER TOEE FL
OMKELI S PHIETNG CPLEOELDOU
TA AWA AYNDEL TLHE TIR
SIEFRNDT I WASY EASND A
UNABTARSNDUG ELENO T THO
LEL
RTHEIDSRI FEN IEDEA LRNHI T
S
GTHIN HBO AUTOWEM M WYORKSOR
NNS
IWER UNDANSTD WTHAPE HAP
AWHEND WOR IS ON THEIP TF O
MY TGUONE.
EAERHA CPT I WASGOP HINO T
VEGI LOO'SET L UKERNDHE TOO HD
TH
IISSOW HEM MYOR WKSORT' IS
NOONEOWN SOUC MH BUT I'M
NO
TI WTRI -NG -RI WNGTIND A
OGURNEOLEXALIC T AOOTBK. ATLL
HE H'SOWEM MYOR W TKSORSHI
IS
HA WTNSAP HPEHE W INST' NOT
INWORK AGND W.HY
E HDERRE AE SOM TSIP FOR
WHEL HPSOU YREM M OYORR
IMESOVT IIK LEAG MAN
GIN
SSSTREETND A GNGTIHNO EUG
EESLPT WHAAN CMPAITR IHE T
ENFFDIERWE BCEETENHE ALZ
ES
NANDMAORLTTOR FGEGIN.
WSOEAN WTO T RZEOGECNIRE THE
TN' A SENPLUPEMT IN THE
WORY EDVEANDYBO W TTSO
LESUPPNTMERY EVE WDYBOTSAN THE
GIMAC PLIL HOW DO IP STO
WVIHANGTUDSOR SNCK OHE T TIP
YOF MON TEGU SHAO W CTAN I DO
BEEM REMRE WRHE I PKEARDY M
CA
SNEER I A'TEMUP SPLHETEN T
NSBRAI AREIG DESNDNE I A WAY
LWE'L GET O -NE -GE FORT
THUL RGSEGORLYAR F
EREV.
INI FT TDHAUREA RSSGIN.
THNES I O OF THEIG BSTGE
APEHOSHEND T TNREHES IHE T
APTIXND AHE T BKACT THAS I
HIE TIS LTF OHA W TTO DO T
OVIMPRR YEOUYEM MORAY D
TO
OPPELEIK LEHA TT.
RE TTHE IS THEDE IA IT IS ON
PMOMERY IADAROXST I AEALL
BI
G DLEAEN ESSORALTI FHE T
ONNCFUTIFGIN OTLM AOS
EV WHIYTNG A DEOND OUR
IDOTYTI TBEEM REMRO T IM A
WDHO I HEAV BNEEUT BO ALS
T SHUC A BNGEIEA DLAU BECSE
ITGE FORTSOS M EINRYVETH
GEV
LYTUENAL
'T DUONBEEM REMT LRAS
EE K
ASOR LTH MTON VYEREL WLE W
ERMEREMBAN ADFFUL OSHI TNG
FR
TOMHET PAS YREALL REA
YWE
.LL
ATTHS I OYKA.
>>SREHE I AEN ZAY SGINN I
RTHEIOUF I YAN CET GHE T.RE
DONL F'TEEN IHE TRELL AHE T
UTMETI B IE HAV ENCERXPIEE
TWITHENHE STISAON IAN C'T
RETERMB I RS ILLEAY
TRFRUSINATG IOU W LLDEOV TO
MBREME E TERHECTXAHI TNG
ALPEESCI A ALYS PIOFEROSSLNA
ITERANOU Y W TTOOR REP
TAC
LYRACUTE
T ATTHEE SAMIM TEOU Y HEAV
A SSEENHA TT I KWNO THE
NCSEEF OT WHA'M I SINAYG
HEATTH TAR LOIRGE PNTS IRE THE
NOHA TT IL WIL FHTIG T
STADEILL W IIL FURIGEUT O A
WA
TYOET GHE TMF IHE TYRE A
NO
ITNY MIN BRAIG R. NHTOW
BU
ITFOU YE HAV TOEHO COS
TEETWNHEGE LARRRU TTHHE T
ABCOLLEATORIVECER PSPVETI ON
INMESOTHGHA TTAP HNEPEDND A
TVIHANGNEUNLIS VNIO MOREMYF O
THLCT AUAHING YOU SAWND A
HE T ADTTHAEN MOMNT IIM TE
LD WHEOUIN DEF CELITYOSHOE THE
ERLARGREIC PTU
DR HEUNES TEDIMUT OF O 100
TH IHA WTSO SAT GREBO AUT
BE
UMGIN H TANOAV HET THA FLD
IO VOFIS
YESUR OIN BRASRE A REMBEEMR
TH SUS JTRETO TOD BYF O
LEKNOWOUEDG Y TET GHET JUS OF
.IT
IWHATUT BSEABOULIF AUTIN LIVG
YTODAT THA LEIFS I ANPE ON
BO YES TTOU CANOO L AKTHE T
S.TADEIL
TH'TOE DSN UAK ME DSBEUMR IN
ANYAY WIT WH THELI ABI
TTYO
LEGOOG THE NEAM.
E WWEERDI HOLLLNG A OFT THA
RMINFO IIOATN H ONURDSEA
BE
REFONTHE T INEERT.
NOE W CAN EANXPDHA WTE WAN C
US
E WE GETHE TUS J OTFHA WTS I
OINGOG INDHO SUL SAY TREHE
AR
P 1E00PLEOE WHOAV HE
DI OSENODN THETLA PNEYIG HHL
ORPESURIIOUT AOBCAAPGRHI
RYMO TYHEBEEM REMRN I GATREE
DERY EILVEAY DF OHE T
LI SSOY THE DEMO RBEEMRAS LT
EKWE'SOR MNGNIRHO SWE ANDLL A
THEX TTSA MESUTSGE BOR FE SOM
SFOLK TSHIS I A SWEERUPPO
RMA
LRYOURUN HTE HASHI THE T
ACNDSES A C ITTHAEDH WITER H
SEIMLRA T AND SHE IS IN
TH
OO BK.
RII T TEDOTO SP HER AND I
DNCOUL.'T
KETA AE DAT AUST h
19.
AS W AUR SATY IIT VIS
ED
TJOHNA.VORALT
SHHEAD H T WLEHOAY D ANDT WHA
PE HSAPNNGNI I THEEW NSND A
WH
SATHEE WORND A WTHA THE
HEWEATRAS W.
LYTUACAL IHR TEW ANATEHA TT
MIET HERND A SHEAI SDHA TT
TH YAT DEOUE.ET M M
SHE LESOVT I ISOT NHE T
PESURPHAEROW T YTOUND A I
INIMAG IEDTOU W BE.
'T CEYANP STOEL RINIVG THE
WO
AYTRS D OSFHE T LIRESIV IN
FULLHN TECOLICORET DLAIO IT
CA
D LNEAO TAL PARINYZG
DE.SIESON
SERTHE' A FOUAMS MAN AE CAS
ST
NYUD ISCEU NRONCIEE HE
REERMBEDVE EGTHRYIN AND
CODOR MEMEIZAS MVE
TIANQUTIES OFT TEX IN A
NREFOIGAGAN LGU
AEND
EMMATH FICATALSMUORLAIDE H D
NOSTND UERMPDAN I
FEERCT
ILDETARS YEAAT LER TTHAE H WAS
IMIRLY DAIEC BSEAUHE TRES I
ACNO BDROKGUN FR OUNEGORRO
NGYTERHIAS W RREEMEMBET WDHAEV
SWANI MEAFUNGL WASUS JT AS
MBREMESEDER ASENC IONALENQUTI
SO B WEASDENE BY TTHA.
T IS I RLLEAYFU USEORL FUR O>
AB
ITILY TOCT FUNNIO.
>> IS ITYEA RLLRU T TETHA NOT
TVIHANGEMO R ABEEMRLL THE
EPHONRSUM NBEEAVE TO
JMBMEEROTUS TTA SYN IOU TCH
WI
THEO PEPLE WOU WLDE HAV
BTTLILEUTKSOO BOW N WE D'TON
RE SERMB AGLINEAY MBENE OR O
HAOTW T ATRELD OHO PNEBE NUM
RS
ITHATRE GWP U WH.IT
ISHA TT RLLEAYKA OYR O ARE WE
INGETTY LGAZBO AUT TOM SEESYP
OR MOFEM I AYNDHA TTOR WSE
IULWOD BTETE BET IRFE W
SEEREXCIHA TTT POR - -AR PTF O
K.QUICMOR ATL LITE BITOR ME
>>OV LEHI TSUE Q IIOSTN
ST
EMLIL R ABEEMR MLLY
OOILCHDHEN FDRINE PDSHO
NUUTSER BET Y I LLYERITAL
N'DOT KWNOY M TWOOU YESNGT
KI NHO PNE.BEUMRS
ION D'TNO KWT WHA AHE TY.RE
MS SATEE BIK LEADEN PARNGTITH
RI
ERT GHTHE.
GH[LAUR]TE
>> HUTE'ERS THEUE QIOSTN I
DUL ASKEEO PPLMM ILYIAEDTE
ASS TMEHIS I BAD.
UL SIHO BDEOR MEMINIZG TSEHE
IINTHGSD USE TOEMORE
EON NBEUMRST THA BTEETR FOR
WH
?AT
OUEAR YOI GNG TOMP IVEROR YOU
YILABIT TO RREMEMBETH OER
IINTHGSOUF YIZEM MOR AEOZ D
EN
EPHONRSUM NBE?
KN
I YLLOUROMPVE YROULI ABITY
ETETH DFLSAI O A DTAUMOCEN
RYFI
YLMOUEDAT WCH OR THEOO BK
YOUEA RD?
ETHE B ARTEEBLO T YIN FDROU
WONPHETNHE IOE GSSI MISNG IF
MYOUEOREMIZ D AENOZHO PNE
NUS?ER
CUANIZEM MOR,0 1E0000
OGIDITS PFI IF YOUAN WDTE
.TO
CIAN SITOW DNHR TGHOU
TIPERETI M AONNDBEAY
IOCISOATNS IOULDBEEM REM
RMY
REHI CLDSN'NE PHOUM NRSBE
AN AOZ DER OENTHS.
NO PBLROEM.
SN DATOERO I'TMP MVEY MOREMY
AB
FITILYOR MOREM OINIZGERTH
INTHGS WVETSHAOER.
IT ISNOE'TROMPVEY MIF LE
ECABEUS I'T DOND NEE TO
ME
IRIMOZE
T.
I VET. I
R SRTMASHO PNE ARE THE
ALTEEXRNNATIZIOF O
URME
RYMO.
SIT INTUG AMEIOATN.
AN COB JHA SRE THEOB J OF
ITRYMO W OHUR P INEHOSN CLOOE
WA TTHASN DOEAV'T HEO TE B
FEL.FU
I WREASS GLAESEC BSE MYS EYE
ELEDNE HIN SPEE
TON D'TWINKHI TCEBO AUT
.THAT
AN CSE UGL GOO OERY M
TSNTCOACEMO T RBEEMRSHI TNG
FOE MO TP HELID A IN
REGERMBIN.
SN DATOEAI I'TMP MRY
RIMEMOLI AESBI TTYOO DTH OER
TH N IGSSOTIK LE AAV H'T
ZEMOMERIDHO PNEUM NRSBEOW N I
TTSI A THE CCHOUNGTA SRIT A
TH WROLAL D
INOLG.
AS ALD WORE WRE AUS BRIESI UNG
RAROU BORSIN MN THA ERVEE W
HN'DOTNOEAV EOWHUG DIMNTE
PR WLYAB IAS AID K WNHE WE
EDROV INHE T CARE WTA S ODREUT
NDE THWI.OW
TEAU[LGH
DOO LKET A THELD WOR NOW I
EDSTLIENO T A PCAODST AND I
REOMERMB S I OEFT TO TLEL
UBO A IUTTIZEM MORGINHO PNEYO
NUSSER IOT NSS CRONGAITRNI
ITOTLIL NEL HPOU INER OTH
.YS
RI H>>EA S YNGOUAYT IHA TT WAY
CO
IMEHI TNK I NOT OYNLEE AGR
OUTHWI Y I WLDOUE TAKT I A
ST
TH FEPUR IERT IS JTUS
AN MTADOLKI LEOONG AT MELYSF
OUI W SLDAY F MY OWNE LIF
INOW MNY M-ID F, TIIFESI
ULWOD SAY IHI TNKY MIF LEAS H
IM
IOVPRED MNYLL SKIS HEAV
OVIMPRR OEDVEHE TAS L5T 2
YE
NSAR IHA TT IM AER WIS
USBECAON IE DAY'T PS AUC MH
IOTEATNT E TNORYVEEIT LTL
TADEIL AND ANK THI MEORBO AUT
ETHIG B PTUICREVE ENHE TNHE WN
I
DHO SULE BEM REM
RIBENG
ILDETARA IS T MEDINELYSF TO
BIGREIC PTU.I MO TEORF OHE T
HAKIN T HTASE MADE M AOR ME
REINTEINSTGNER PSO WHOAN C
BUNTCORI T OTENDEHE I LAELEV A
LILEIT BHA T. ATRE
ON D'TAN WTO T PNTAIT I AS A
GA TUT BT'HAS A LTLUNE HCH
IBOEAV AEL MUTYS
F.>NT OO
HA I TNKOU Y ARE
THSOMEG.IN
IERTHESHE TEM M FYOROR THE
FSTUF YOUW. KNO
EEM STIANCYEM MOR AND THE
AC
MULAON OFNO KEDWLGE.
DTHAT DSNOE'THINIMISIT WH
E.AG
PRSINGED SPE SWSLON DOW
STIMEMEEEOU Y FOUL Y CANEE SO
HEETH WSELUR TNGNI.
TH
ATAP HNSPE.
T BUWE'T DON HEAV THE
STHEOUFFTU YAV HEEA LNEAEEDRN
SSTAY YIT WH HOUEAV THE
MUACCU BTILAVEFYOD OMIS WDO
TH
IATSRET BTEHA TN ER.VE
OUATWH YNO KWOW NER V5SSU 2
AN L AOT OFS U A WSEET G
OURDE YE HAV THEYEM MOROR F
TH TUS JTHEOR MEMY FOR
EPNCTS ANDRNAT PTEES W HEAV
DLIVEHNO EUG TOAV HEHI TS
ENPEEXRI ACENDOT NEDICHE TRE
AISIL SIMAR PTEATRN NOW IAN C
KEMA CIOCLONUSED BNSAS ON TSHI
BO
ODYFEDNO KWL IGE WLDOU NOT
NDVEHA UDSTEROO IHE WNAS W
YORGEIEEM MOR FSOR THEFF STU
NOWE KUM AWCCATULEVE ORE TIM
AN
ADSE WGE A WE AREE MOR
NEATTU TDOAT P ARNTESND
TEPNCTSNHA WEER WEO SHI TS
IS
HE WREHE TYAY SMIS WDOES COM
WIGE AN I PTARSEEC BAUF O
.THAT
>> WT'HASTHA I KPEELI TELNG
MYLF.
OWSO N'S LET GET AIT LETL
RKDA.
ISTHOO BKL WIL SLELLI M 2ILON
SPICOESOTI STALYICSTALS I
TH L?OW
ST'AY S M 100LIILONOP CSIE
TASO SALSTTIICLYHO TSE
IOMI0 LLNEO PEPLDR HUNFSED O
IOMILL P ONSF WPLEOELIL SEE
THEOO BKO SAS BALICLYHE T
OLWHEOR W WLDLILE COM IONT
COITTAC WHHI TSK
OO BK.
OSOMESE TFHOEEO PPL
TIATSTISLLCAY PLLSOERNA BYET A
THNIEG BIN ONGFHE ALZ
ERIS
NOOR KEO SWOMNE ORVEBS OER
E.MESOON
HEIN T SEAMIT WH TSHI
WRVTEIEEE SNY B 1ONIL BLI
PE.LE
SLET'AL TK TO TSEHOE.EO PPL
IWHAT AS DINTUISRBNG TGHI TO
NOCET THA I'TSNMA NOR
LFU
INTINCON
T IATSNG THEHIE W LOOUT O
FOR?
H IATSNGPEAPNI YOUHO SDUL
SEEU A NSTLOROGIR OOM SE
SIBAC.ES TTS
>>NE O OHE T TNGHIS I AM
DIPOUN P TNGHETEMAVEN
S I
ALNORMINIZGIN BRAEA HHLT.
TTIN PEOOMEPL CLERTFOAB
TABOGIN AUTRA BIN HLTEAH.
AWEREER PCTFELY HPYAP TO GO
TOMA PURRIRYAR CECIHY PSIAN
HEDAN C OCKUTUR OEA HRTLT HEAH
AN
D GETLO BODEN TAKR O A
AICERTBE NNUM S ORFPSTEN I A
DAY.
ABUTGTHNYIN TRO FMHEEC NKP U
HIWE T WNKEAV HE NONF IENLUCE
EROV.
LD WOUE LIKO TEE SPL PEO
E
GBEINONVEATIOH WNITHE TIR
DO
ORCT.
ETHESHERE A TNG THIS IM A
FO
NGETRGTI.
SISTH IT WHA MYTIOG CNIVE
FALHETHIKLSEE LE.OD TAY
.OKAY
XTPP ANTNTOIMEE WPA COM
RE
YTHISERREA V NSSUTEXR YEAR O
LA YR.EA
IATSON CG?RNCEIN
TI
OPFHE T TGUONE.
IATSIS HAM NESHA WT'HE T
NA TF OHEIE MOV?
TI TF OHEON TEGUS INOM CMO
FO
ARLLF OS U WTHHEER0 2R O
ENIT T TDSOE BRO PUNNOSO SO N
OLBILYICOGALINPE SAKT TGHAS I
LI C ALALHE TAC SK.
AR'SIT H TDO GET TO ASOS OPPED
TO A CMOOMNOR WDT' ISY EAS TO
MECOY. B
OUIF Y H LEAVSOTF OIP TF OHE T
MTOWN TIEOVLEITSR OCT ASORR O
ONPERSE, NSAMON D'TWE SAT IT.
BU NHE TEAM OF THENG THIHA TT
IRI WTE WHIT.
HIETH T.NG
TE WIRI OOR WDSNHE TAP P
ER
TH.
A P?EN
OR WDSHA TT ARENOM CMO GLOA
G.SSMIIN
ISNSAP HPE TOUR ORI F
DEN
GCRAIAYLL A DG. LON
HIETH T INGRI DNKAT WERRO F
M
DALLAYONG.
HAIF T ITSNIAP HPEOUNG YRI BNG
OATTH T DOU YRTOOCR.
THS I CINCEONRNG.
OUIF YOS LEOU YRS KEY ANDR YOU
ONPHET THAOU CLDE B IN
IOTEATNT ONRIS DONACTRTI
PRUTMLE BF I YOU FDINOU YR
NDYSKE AHO PNEND AHI TNKHA WT
DOO DH WIT TSHI WHY DO I
EDHI TSF IOU YOO LK AT YROUE
PH S AENDYDEUDNLNK THI I
DO
NOTN' K HWOW TOOR WKHI TS
THWIHA TT GTCLIHTOM MENHA TT
ISINCEONRN TGT'HASFE DIFNTRE
MOREHA TNIS DENACPLEM DTUE TO
AT PIONTN SPLEOENO CAYANT
ERMEREMB IHE WREAR PDKE MY
CA
N IATSMAORLND A AN
ATIONTNUE ISSG GRE ORI'BEN
WI
R NLLOTZEOGECNI HISAR C HE
ND SLLTAN IRO FNT OFT I
N'ESTOM CTEPUHA TTON BELGSO
TORIM OE DSNOE'TBEEM REM
RHO
HWE GOT TREHE.
K BEOOS IUT ABO HIMS A A
ACPREFR OEVEND A ORVEND A SAY
'T DIONW KNO HOT IOW GE. HER
TH
HE'SAT TIR FSTHI TNGO T GO
IN
LL A'S - -HE ALZ IERIM'SS
THCAIP HPOUSMPHE TAR PT TTHA
ISEC N FSAESRYOREW N
SLCINSOUD HYELIEEM MOR
BT
HEIF TRA B IINSER UNDKTT AAC
ANUYO CGI IMANEHA TT
ATFOINRMHANIO TTEC RTLENY
ENHAPPEDIL WLOT N GONT IO A
GSTLAINYEM MORO S IAN C'T
REAVERMB HRIGIN DN THE T
TORSTEAPTHA H ANEPEDEW F
ATENUSN SGOWA FOR THEOW H I
GOTER HE.
OUIF YRE A RNGEAEPTIELOU YRSF
LAOTAU BECOUSE YON D'T
YMBMEEROUD TOLEB SOMYODE
INMESOTH IGFOU YEA REP
T
SEYOUROT ALF LUT BOU YON D'T
MBREMEIS, ERTHS I A
ERCONVTION TORI BNGO TOU YR
PRYARAR CE PANSIHYCI.
LTEEADEAEIK HLT HRTEAHEH T
DOEATN' M INF IE HAV A
RORYMO PEMBL IL WIL FLALFF O
TH
ELI CFFF O-S ENDGETA
ALSMEEIR'OR TOMWRO.
ITIK LE DEA HRTEAISSE WE
AYVEHA W WSE CANVE PRENTND A
PRHEGON TNCIS DTA AENDH PUS
EIALZH WR'MES I OAYFFONT THE
DIYCEAN BOI DNGHE TIG RHT
TH Y FGSORROUIN BRALT HEAH.
WE
NO KW HRTEAHYEA HLT
MEEARRTEANT DNIEAN CUC REDE
YO
HE AURLZ RERIM'SYKIS BAL H
E WAD H AL PILS AT IL WIL
CEREDUALY B H YFOUOU WLDAK TE
IT SGEPLEINENET BWE SEV AND
OUNENI H ARSHT NIGS IEL HUG
YIM
T.RTPOAN
IAN CL TEL YOUT IUP SER
IM TANRTT GOETLE SEPRY EVE
GHNIT.
ILISTH WP HLELOU YOC LK INHE T
ESMOMERIHAF O W YTOUEDRE CAT
TO
NEARDTU SFFROOM TORNDW A
ENPREVHE ATLZ.ERIM'S
AYOK.
NLTBU UOUSES YEL TLE M. WHY
AYI SHI T IS WTHA THERA BIN
IS WNGOILEHIOU YLE S.EP
SOOU Y KWNOVE ERYIM TEOU Y CAN
GIVERS YOUFELENET BWEEV SEN
INDAN NRS HEOU OFEP SLE.
TDON' AOR WRYUTBOHE TRS YEA
HYOUEAVLEOT N SPT
GH[LAUR]TE
REUYO ATI SLLKA OY.
T WSOHAL WIL YOUO D? NOW
RE T>>HEAS W. A
LY MEIFRE WHE IUG THO
HT
PSLEES IOR F SKERS IOU W
LD
GFEEL ALTUIY GUTBOTIETNGOO T
MUCH.LE SEP
>>OM SEEO P SEPLLLTIL FEE TTHA
Y IUT PUT ABO THEOR IMP
NE
LEOF SNDEP A A LOT OFME COM
ST
AYTO S IETIN N HERSOU AND I
FEO S GLTUIY.
WDES A A CTUULRERE A LEIK
TH AREAZOU Y LY?
AR GOU YTIETNGHNO EUGON DE?
W>>EY ONL H TEAVWO ORHR TEE
MIUTSTE BET L'SPE SND ONER O
TW
OOFM THEEO PEPLEE NDO T
RSUNDENDTALE SEPS IOT NDAS WTE
.TIME
EVMA AYNIL NDSEE SEPLE.
WH
Y?
USBECA B OEURINRASRE A
IDNSCOOLINATG THE MS.OREMIE
WEDEE THEIM TE TO KPEE THE
NBRAIUNND A FNGIOCTNIRD OER
DAAY TOD
.
>> WHY WLDOU ALL LINIVGNG THIS
VOVEHA EEDLVO TEEV DOTO T SO
MU
E TCHIMLE SINEPG?
WE YNTPERSEAF O OURIV LEST
THOI PNTN O SEPLE ITS IOT N
TE SATA OFNG DOIOT NNGHIE W
EAROT NON CIOSCUSHA TTUR O
BOS I SERUPUS BYNG DOI
GSTHIN AHA TTRETISS EENOAL T
THHEA HLTND AIOUN FCTFNGNI O
YEVER SRG OAN ITEYSMNUR OOD BY
WE NTUSDEE TO CDASOONLITE
ME
CRIMOESWAARLE AY THE
MELIBOCRI DEBS IST'AL VIT TO
ENURYO MEALTA HHLT
VARDCAIOULSCAREA HHLTND AO T
NOANET G C BRCEUT ITAS H
EDHELP TOL FKSND UDSTERANY M
AAIBRNY BNDODRE AUS BY
NGEACLNI UPHI WLE ILE SEPT' I
S
ANOTTA S OTEFNC UUSSCONIO
INNOTHG.
G>>ETOR MEEP SLEND A D'TON
GFEELLTUIYEE FLIK LEOU YAV HE
ET SNEOMNGHIRA CZYRS YOU
FEL
TJUSTOO DHA TTVE ERYAY D.
DOYWOT RRBO AUT THELE SEP
YO MAV HESED IN THET PAS
WE
LLE'V AON DEFF STUHA TTS I
WUPSTID CANE BRT SMAERND A
WI
ORO N M AENDO DTE BETRPENT
THEEAS H BNUC SH A PGEVIRILE
TU
WIGRAHT MADTLM AOSNE OST
ITURHO WENUTHO MGONTIINUD RY.
GH[LAUR]TE
HA TEV NERKEALDO TNY A
ING
ABOUS TTHIND A NOT TKALUT ABO
RU.
LS AOKE SPO WHITSE THO
LL0 10MIOPNIO CHASIE T ITT
DE
TRVSEESL. SOEL
I CNOANTAI WTO TEE ST WHA YROU
NE
OXTNE ISN O AND WEIL WL
TABO AUTHA TTN WHE.
ITAN CNOT WAI TOEE SOU YN I
IFALRE L
AYOM SEDOO SN.
>> TEAKE C